eröffnen möchte ich die runde gerne mit
den eindrücken von paul ronzheimer paul
wie bei der heutige kriegstage was ist
hier passiert du warst vor ort
janina vielen dank dass ich auch heute
wieder bei viertel nach acht über die
situation hier die dramatische situation
in der ukraine sprechen kann ich war
heute mit meinem kameramann jorgos botha
fuß unterwegs bei ihr team das ist ein
vorort von kiew ungefähr 20 autominuten
entfernt und was ich dort gesehen habe
hat mich wirklich nachhaltig schockiert
war an dem board an den gestern raketen
eingeschlagen sind es war in der nähe
einer kirche menschen die schon alles
gepackt hatten die ihre koffer dabei
hatten und die weg wollten aus der stadt
wegrennen wollten wurden von einer
russischen rakete getroffen zivilisten
sind zivilisten anders als putin das mit
seinen lügen uns glauben machen will
diese stadt wird so heftig bombardiert
dass man sich vorstellen kann was hier
auf kiew noch zukommen wird die
zerstörung ist riesig und auch als wir
dort waren sind menschen durch einen
fluss an einer kaputten brücke in
richtung sicherheiten gerannt und sie
konnten auch dort natürlich keine echte
sicherheit finden denn es gab schüsse es
gab gefechte menschen sind nervös
losgerannt dort raus anders als ich
haben sie keine schutzweste oder ein
schutzhelm der sie vielleicht ein
bisschen schützen kann vor
raketenangriffen
und dann hat mich ein statement eines
jungen mannes beeindruckt oder zumindest
zum nachdenken bewegt der auch
ausgekommen ist aus ihren plänen aus
dieser stadt und der gesagt hat wie
könnt ihr das alles mitmachen warum tut
ihr nichts warum schließt ihr den
luftraum nicht warum gibt es keine
flugverbotszone
und ich weiß dafür gibt es sicherlich
viele
geopolitische gründe die aus sicht der
deutschen dagegen sprechen würden wir
reden immer über die angst dass wir in
diesen mit reingezogen werden das mag
alles richtig sein aber aus sicht dieses
mannes der gerade alles hinter sich
gelassen hat er sein ort vielleicht nie
wieder sehen wird der hat die frage an
mich gerichtet warum tut deutschland
nicht mehr warum kann russland raketen
auf uns regnen lassen und das ist etwas
was ich heute mitgebracht habe und diese
schmerzhafte frage auch möchte dass sie
in der runde diskutiert wird
ja die war paul ich muss auch sagen die
letzten wochen waren absolut beschämend
ich habe mich teilweise so hilflos
gefühlt und habe manches mal gedacht ist
es eigentlich richtig teil dieses
politischen berlins zu sein ich habe
mich wirklich manches mal geschämt dafür
und genau bei dieser frage was tun wir
eigentlich diese frage mir auch immer
wieder selbst gestellt tun wir
eigentlich viel zu wenig wenn ich
gesehen habe dass es wochen lang
gedauert hat bis die 5000 helme die
alleine schon witz waren überhaupt mal
angekommen sind wenn es dann alleine
schon wieder sechs tage gebraucht hat
bis die panzerabwehrraketen und singers
in die ukraine geliefert worden sind das
teilweise dann anschließend bei den
nächsten raketen verschimmelte raketen
dabei waren dann frage ich mich
ernsthaft ob es das ist was wir leisten
können ich finde dass es zu wenig und
deswegen haben wir als junge union ja
auch dazu aufgerufen mehr zu tun was
würden sie mehr tun herr kuban wir haben
ja auch noch sanktionen verhängt die
deutsche wirtschaft ja jetzt auch schon
treffen genau seine sind ja die
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen das ist ja
auch richtig dass wir diese
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen machen wir
haben in erheblichem maße dort uns auch
bewegte ich glaube gerade am anfang gab
es auch noch ganz andere diskussion wir
werden ja auch noch mal später über das
thema embargo diskutieren aber es geht
auch um die frage was wir militärisch
liefern können was wir den ukrainerinnen
und ukrainer zur verfügung stellen
können in diesem brutalen
angriffskrieg von wladimir putin und da
glaube ich dass unsere bundesregierung
das eben auch unsere industrie noch
deutlich mehr liefern kann wenig sie
sind der ukrainische botschafter wenn
ich sie jetzt frage was braucht die
ukraine ein militärischer ausrüstung was
würden sie fordern also wir haben zwei
listen an die bundesregierung geschickt
die eine schon vor über einem monat da
ging s eben vorrangig über diese
luftabwehrraketen und anti panzer
raketen und sachen sowie aufklärung nach
sich geräte so ähnlich ist also die für
ausstattung für die truppen dienen und
die zweite liste erst letzte woche und
diese zweite liste sie beinhaltet schon
eine gesamte palette von von den
waffensystemen da sind auch panzer
gepanzerte wagen auch flugzeuge und
schiffe das ist alles was was wir in der
tat heute brauchen würden denn ein
panzer konnte als offensivwaffen noch
vor ein paar wochen angesehen werden
aber heute ist ein panzer wenn ein
walzer das dorf von oder gstaad ihn
beschützen könnte von den seychellen und
die dort jetzt ein teil gesetzt haben
und auch die umgebung da sind brutalste
leute deswegen auch ein panzer in eine
solche situation könnte eine defensiv
waffe sein und deswegen sind wir im
gespräch mit
verteidigungsministerium mit der
industrie auch parallel denn wir wissen
dass die bundeswehr natürlich selbst
viel gerät braucht und das ist jetzt
jeder tag ist entscheidend für uns wir
versuchen gerade auch selbst mal zu
klären was auflage ist was die deutsche
industrie und deutschland ist ja der
viertgrößte exporteur von waffen was da
schnellstens geliefert werden kann mit
der unterstützung der regierung es ist
jetzt so dieses konzept das wir
versuchen auf die beine zu stellen aber
jeder zahlt jeder tag zählt und die zeit
läuft uns davon
der punkt ist glaub ich hab botschaft
hat er machen kann sie haben es hier mit
deutschland zu tun einem land das
eigentlich sich quasi entmilitarisiert
hat und ich glaube da kommen wir zum
kern des problems tema-q bahn hat ja
gerade angesprochen was passiert es den
letzten wochen wie lange es gedauert hat
überhaupt 5000 helme zu liefern das
system mehr geliefert wurden die gar
nicht mehr einsatzfähig sind seit 2012
gar nicht mehr benutzt werden dürfen
eigentlich nach unserem standard dasein
wurden eigentlich geliefert treffen aus
wurde nur eine zusage erteilt von der ba
von der behörde aber das ministerium das
zuständig ist hat gar nicht die zusage
erteilen das heißt diese austria also
pfeil raketen der symmetrischen sind
immer noch in deutschland ja aber es
wäre glaube ich auch schlimm wenn sie
geliefert werden weil man gar nicht weiß
genau sie dürfen hier würden ich habe
mit dem verteidigungsminister gesprochen
und und das thema geschilderte sagte
wenn das möglich ist schick schick
sofort das was was einsatzbereit wäre
aber es ist noch nicht so weit also wir
warten immer noch dass diese entscheiden
kommt und auch wieder andere waffen
geliefert werden dann eine waffe einst
in der kette könnte ein helikopter
abschießen das vorher vielleicht
wohnhäuser bord hat wir hören hat aus
der bundesregierung dass es das heißt
wir wissen gar nicht welche waffen wir
schicken sollen wir haben das dilemma
jetzt ja auch wieder gesehen am
vergangenen wochenende oder in der
letzte woche es ist einfach nichts da
und da kommen sie zum kernproblem dieses
land ist eigentlich entmilitarisiert und
wie wir aufhören von einem hohen
generieren die sagen wir sind eigentlich
blank was die eigene verteidigung angeht
wie soll man da einem anderen land wie
der ukraine stehen politische abwägungen
dass man natürlich auch immer schaut auf
die reaktionen putins herr u bahn haben
sie denn dafür verständnis dass
natürlich auch in der politik darüber
debattiert wird wie wird putin reagieren
auch mit blick auf diplomatische
verhältnisse zueinander er ist ja auch
manche nicht komplett für lieferungen
sind es geht für uns darum auch klar zu
machen wir sind nicht selbst
kriegspartei aber wir unterstützen die
ukraine wo wir nur können und wenn ich
mir anschaue was wir beispielsweise den
afghanen geliefert haben was wir dort
leuten hingestellt haben die bei
erstbester gelegenheit sofort den
rückzug angetreten haben und abgerückt
sind und die sachen einfach übergeben
haben dann frage ich mich das kann nicht
unser ernst sein dass wir den
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer nicht mehr
schwachen zur verfügung stellen und es
stehen definitiv auch noch sachen zur
verfügung der botschaft der magic hat
gesagt jeder tag zählt und das gilt ganz
besonders für unsere bundesregierung wir
wollen nicht kriegspartei werden aber
wir wollen ja rina bestmöglich
unterstützen
pauli
hatte ich ihnen ja also das ist ja alles
gut und schön ja das ist alles gut und
schön was die waffen angeht und das ist
auch ganz wichtig aber jetzt hat keiner
eigentlich auf die frage geantwortet die
mir der junge mann heute bei ihr
gestellt hat nämlich warum gibt es keine
möglichkeit einer flugverbotszone das
hat ja auch der ukrainische präsident
angesprochen der sich sehr enttäuscht
von der nato und europas gezeigt hat und
die menschen sagen putin lässt raketen
auf uns regnen und die westliche welt
tut nichts es gibt keine flugverbotszone
man tut nichts um den luftraum zu
befreien von russischen raketen
dort ist doch der grund wenn ich direkt
beantworten darf ich finde diese debatte
auch sehr sehr wichtig der grund ist
doch dass wladimir putin wird die
korrigiert mich wenn ich jetzt etwas
falsches wieder gebe aber vladimir putin
hat doch darauf hingewiesen dass wenn
die flugverbotszone eingeführt wird dann
sind wir doch eigentlich schon fast
kriegspartei oder nicht
naja das ist das was war die mir putin
sagt aber wladimir putin spricht viele
drogen die ganzen tag aus
auch gegen deutschland gegen die
westliche welt und ich habe ja gesagt
ich verstehe durchaus
die argumentation und dennoch ist es
eine finde ich finde ich wirklich eine
schwierige eine schwierige frage und
wenn man sie aus der ukrainischen
perspektive betrachtet hat sie ja
durchaus
seine berechtigung
ja die frage ist natürlich berechtigt
und die auch die forderung von lohme
selensky ist absolut berechtigt
nur für uns ist natürlich eine
abwägungsfrage wollen wir da können wir
kriegspartei werden oder können wir es
nicht werden und ich bin wir haben eben
gerade über die entmilitarisierung
deutschlands gesprochen die hdj deutsche
können dass am ende nicht alleine
entscheiden das gehört zur wahrheit auch
dazu sondern wir müssen es gemeinsam in
der nato entscheiden und wenn ich mir
anschaue dass wir 2015 auch in syrien
das ganze zumindest mal diskutiert haben
übrigens auch im spiel in diskussion
stand wo angela merkel als
bundeskanzlerin das auch ins spiel
gebracht hat weil eben dort gift
eingesetzt worden ist giftgas eingesetzt
worden ist und deswegen sage ich schon
es müssen am ende von seiten des westens
auch klare rote linie definiert werden
und klar gesagt werden wenn putin diese
roten linien überschreitet dann sind wir
auch bereit am ende eine
luftverkehrs nur verbotszone
einzurichten ein remake haben sie
verständnis dafür dass deutschland
zögert und die westlichen staaten mit
blick auf die flugverbotszone
ja sie haben selbst gehört das was paul
ronzheimer vor ort spürt und sieht also
die ukraine können das nicht
nachvollziehen auch mein präsident hat
das mit drastischen worten kritisiert
diese haltung wir glauben dass das auch
ein
messer in den rücken der ukrainer ist
dass man einfach sich durch diese angst
quasi leiten lässt und dass die einzige
was entscheidend ist diese drohung von
herrn putin und wie gesagt man könnte
auch an drohen ja wir würden das machen
und schauen also was geschieht das heißt
man man man putin definiert ist das
spiel und unter westen hat angst und ein
auch in den großen schritt zu
unternehmen das heißt es gibt viele
möglichkeiten wie man diese no fly zone
einrichten könnte nicht nur über die
nato weil dann hat natürlich putin
vielleicht sofort quasi dieses bild dass
feinde sondern auch über die uno zu
versuchen das zu tun mit anderen staaten
die da quasi in einem in einer allianz
der willigen das heißt da gibt es eine
reihe von möglichkeiten hauptsache das
ist der politische wille da ist und
anscheinend fällt dieser würde auch ich
habe den eindruck ich erst einmal fragen
darf das in der nato von bestimmten
ländern ganz besonders gebremst wird wir
wissen dass von der bundesregierung sie
war eine der letzten die überhaupt
zugestimmt hat das sind dass
waffenlieferungen geben darf das auch
das swift-abkommen
in teilen ausgesetzt wird was ist ihr
eindruck welche regierung bremst derzeit
wenn wir einmal die nato raum anschauen
besonders dieser tat deutschland war ja
immer das schlusslicht in diesen fragen
in diesem bei diesem thema weiß ich
nicht ich glaube weil auch die
amerikaner die sind natürlich skeptisch
das muss man auch sagen aber deutschland
kann auch eine führende rolle spielen
das ist nicht so dass man sich immer
wieder verstecken musste und dann erst
wenn die anderen so weit sind ob das
swift ausschluss oder auch
waffenlieferungen
ich glaube deutschland könnte sehr wohl
hier eine initiative starten und sich
nicht nur verstecken und abwarten auf
tauchstation gehen das ist nicht das was
die menschen hier glaub ich erwarten von
der regierung wenig bei swift was sie
gerade angesprochen haben ist ja jetzt
passiert dass china russland aufnimmt
ins verfahren wie viel macht das hat mir
heute mich meine mutter heute morgen
gefragt ehrlich gesagt wie viel macht
haben wir als deutschland überhaupt was
zu verändern wenn dann beispielsweise
china und russland eigentlich gerade
eine verbrüderung vollziehen ich glaube
schon dass das der westen auch seine
machte unterschätzt ja man hat so viel
in der hand vor allem weil die kontakte
auch zu china also massiv sind das heißt
man könnte auch auf ihn einwirken wenn
man sieht dass kinder leider wie wir es
im moment der fall ist den russen in die
karten spielt oder zumindest nicht
kritisiert das was was geschieht ja und
es geht um einen vernichtungskrieg gegen
die zivilisten vor allem weil die russen
ja ihr blitzkrieg ist vielleicht noch
nicht ganz gescheitert aber ins stocken
geraten und deswegen errechnen sie sich
anderen zivilen menschen wie hier in
erwähnen dass es eine stadt wo viele
meiner freunde häuser haben unter einer
der freunde der geflohen ist das haus in
der stadt von wir sind also zwei
kilometer weit wurde samt ja es gibt gar
nichts ja alles alles ist weg und
deswegen der westen muss sich besinnen
auf seinen stärken und die stärke liegt
vor allem in der innen- wie in der
wirtschaft auch gegenüber kinder und
schon gar auf jeden fall gegenüber
russland und deswegen das thema
embargo worüber wir kommen ja berechnet
werden ja das ist das ist der größte
trumpf denn die deutschen in der hand
haben und gar nicht spielen und das ist
glaube ich beschämend